based on the real-life operation dynamo
Christopher Nolan's Dunkirk follows the
evacuation of over 300 thousand soldiers
from a French beach in the opening
stages of World War two visually it's a
masterpiece and one of the most unique
war films to date and for the most part
the movie sticks religiously to the
facts taking inspiration from actual war
photos to frame the action even that
weird-looking sailboat at the end was
there but it doesn't get everything
right you're all the ways Dunkirk lied
about those historical events Nazi nose
cones Christopher Nolan was actually
pretty candid about this historical
discrepancy in the movie the German
planes at Tom Hardy's character fights
have their nose cones painted yellow
that's something the Germans actually
did in the war just not until about a
month after Dunkirk according to Nolan
the reason he decided to adopt the color
scheme for the planes in the movie was a
simple matter of identity during the
dogfights the yellow identifies the
planes as German at a glance
making it easier for audiences to keep
up with the action without trying to
figure out who was who the whole time as
a work definitely French destroyer
Nolan also came clean about another
historical alteration he had to make for
the sake of the film namely filming on a
French destroyer instead of a British
destroyer Nolan said for someone
extremely knowledgeable they'll see the
differences it's a bigger boat and
longer but we dressed it to make it look
like a British destroyer besides being a
detail that only a hardcore history buff
would ever notice the important takeaway
here is that Christopher Nolan filmed on
a real destroyer instead of falling back
on CGI will happily take an extra
smokestack over another battleship Thank
You farriers fuel tank when we first
meet Tom Hardy's character Ferrier he's
already in the air and the movie
announces in a story lasts an hour it's
an intense story arc and we're right
there in the cockpit with him feeling
the pressure as that fuel starts to run
out
he starts with 50 gallons and has to pop
his reserve tank by the time he reaches
Dunkirk
but that's a problem a main fighter used
by the Royal Air Force at Dunkirk was
the Supermarine Spitfire mark 1 there
were fast agile planes with a fuel tank
that could hold 85 gallons giving them a
395 Mile combat range in contrast the
evacuation route the ship's used across
the English Channel was about 55 miles
even accounting for the dogfights and
switchbacks to chase the bomber going
after the British destroyer he should
have had plenty of fuel Spitfires could
fly 220 miles per hour on only 20
gallons of fuel per hour over more time
running out of fuels totally plausible
just probably not in one hour civilian
volunteers we saw the movie how mark
Rylands his character mr. Dawson risked
life and limb to pilot his small sailing
out across the channel and into Dunkirk
in real life a fleet of about 700
private craft assisted the evacuation
effort they were called the little ships
of Dunkirk Jim yeah they were pretty
awesome and it's true that some boat
owners took up the call and sail their
own ships for the evacuation just not
very many according to the association
of Dunkirk little ships the vast
majority of those boats were
requisitioned by the British government
at which point naval officers were
assigned to sail them to Dunkirk and
speaking of the little ships the cavalry
arrives it makes a great heartwarming
climax when the flotilla of little ships
sails up to the beach at Dunkirk but
there was no heroic moment where the
ships arrived to save the day
Operation Dynamo lasted from May 26th of
June for both the little ships and the
British Navy work tirelessly over all 12
of those days and while the movie makes
out the arrival of little ships at the
turning point they didn't rescue the
majority of the soldiers out of the 338
thousand men rescued 239,000 were taken
off the MOL by Navy ships less than
100,000 were picked up off the beaches
and many of those were ferried out to
larger ships by the ship's own Mike
craft only six thousand soldiers made
the trip across the channel in one of
the little ships their contribution to
the evacuation effort can't be
understated of course but it can be
overstated and it often has been the
French Connection at one point in the
movie we see French soldiers clamoring
to get out to the east mole that leads
to the evacuation ships only to get
turned away by a British officer who
tells them that the British ships are
for the British soldiers that's about
the last we hear from the French until
the end when commander Bolton says that
he'll stay behind to help evacuate the
French but the French army was front and
center in Dunkirk of the 338 thousand
soldiers taken off the beach 123
thousand were French soldiers that's
more than a third of everyone who got
rescued as for the French soldiers who
didn't make it off they weren't fighting
to get on an evac vote no they were back
in the actual town of Dunkirk holding
back the Germans while the evacuation
took place estimates put French
casualties at Dunkirk between 50,000 and
90,000 and thousands more were taken
captive because they took a stand and
dug in defend the other soldiers on the
beach
ruins of Dunkirk the majority of
Christopher Nolan's Dunkirk takes place
on the beach at sea and in the air the
trifecta of nolan time that makes up the
narrative of the film however we do get
a few glimpses of the town itself mostly
in the beginning what we see is an
apocalyptic vacancy but no real
destruction except for the pile of
sandbags in one scene it looks less like
a warzone and more like everybody just
left for lunch the exact same time what
should we be seeing utter devastation
between the Luftwaffe bombers and
shelling from the German approach from
the east
Dunkirk was brought to its knees during
the evacuation Christopher Nolan
actually filmed in the town of Dunkirk
which lends historical presence to the
film but it doesn't relate the true
gravity of the situation thousands of
everyday lives ground to a halt the
minute allied troops retreated to
Dunkirk and it took years after the war
to rebuild those lives to something
resembling normalcy thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our YouTube channel let's check out all
this cool stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]